in the summer of 1976 the city of New
York was thrown into a state of terror a
madman was on the loose wandering the
streets and killing people at random
this was a killer who loved publicity
sending vicious taunting letters to the
police and the media each one was signed
with the moniker Son of Sam when fate
finally caught up with the monster he
was revealed to be a chubby introvert by
the name of David Berkowitz in the
biographical video today we discover his
story the child who would become the son
of Sam was born to Richard David Falco
on June the first in 1953 his mother
Betty Broder had been previously married
to a man named Tony Falco but when he
left her for another woman she began a
relationship with a married man named
Joseph Kleinman Betty and Tony already
had a child Roslyn and when Kleinman
found out that she was pregnant again he
pressured her to give the baby up for
adoption it appears that he also forbade
Betty from giving the child his name
which is why she gave the child her
former husband's last name a few days
after birth richard was adopted by a
middle-aged couple named nathan and
pearl Berkowitz who lived in New York
sis Bronx neighborhood the Berkowitz is
owned a hardware store which occupied a
large portion of Nathan's time he was
never close with his adopted son he
recalled David considering the adoption
to be a mistake as David was her only
child pearl was extremely close to the
boy though she indulged David and let
him get away with things that need
shouldn't've David developed into a
difficult child he was hyperactive
mischievous and ornery he was a bulky
child and quickly learns that he could
use his size to his advantage and lauded
over other children he showed little
interest in schooling and through a
combination of truancy and feigned
illnesses he missed class a lot of the
time when he was 7 years old David was
hit by a car and he suffered head
injuries it's unclear whether this
resulted in any long-term effects soon
after though he started to show signs of
a fascination with fire he began burning
bugs and advanced up starting fires
around his neighborhood this didn't
bring him to the attention of the
authorities though his adoptive parents
did take him to see a psychotherapist
when he was 14
David's life was turned upside down with
the death of his adoptive mother pearl
had been fighting breast cancer for two
years Burrell was the only person with
him
David had a close relationship and he
was shocked to watch her decline as she
went through chemotherapy treatments her
death it was a crushing blow in the year
after his mother's death David became
increasingly introverted his schoolwork
suffered drastically as he fell into a
dark depression he had no relationship
with his father and things worsened when
Joseph remarried his new stepmother was
even more distant than his father when
the family relocated to Boynton Beach
near Miami Florida
David's isolation it became complete
with no friends and no family connection
he created a fantasy world in order to
cope with his loneliness in 1971 at the
age of 18 David found a means to escape
his dismal life with his father and
stepmother he joined the army and after
basic training he was sent to Korea
early life it was transformative for the
troubled young man he seemed to respond
well to the discipline that it provided
and generally equipped him well he
trained as a marksman and became a good
shot in 1974 he was honorably discharged
after leaving the army David returns New
York here he was completely on his own
he used money saved during his army
years two rents in apartments in Bronx
and took classes at Bronx Community
College people remember him at this time
as an angry an argumentative young man
who shunned association with others to
support himself he worked a number of
odd jobs including male sought a
security guard and cab driver though
very quiet
Berkowitz quickly came to the attention
of his neighbors and the local police
department he would instigate petty
disputes and escalate them with personal
threats a man who lived on the floor
below deputy police sheriff Charles
Glassman received four handwritten
threats from Berkowitz in his early 20s
Berkowitz connected with his birth
mother he began regular visits with
Betty and his half-sister Rosalynn
however when he found out that Betty had
given him up for adoption after
succumbing to pressure from his birth
father he did not react very well in
fact he cut the two women out of his
life completely never visited again then
in 1974 Berkowitz's fascination with
fire resurfaced over the next three
years he set more than 1,500 fires
around New York City
David diligently recorded the details of
each arson in his journal referring to
himself as
of a phantom of the Bronx fire lighting
gave him some control over his situation
that he couldn't find anywhere else in
his life
in 1975 Berkowitz developed another
fascination and this time it was with
the occult after reading The Satanic
Bible by Anton LaVey the founder of the
Church of Satan he became convinced that
he was being controlled by evil spirits
[Music]
in late November 1975 Berkowitz wrote a
letter to his father in it he said it's
cold and gloomy here in New York but
that's okay because the weather fits my
mood gloomy dad the world is getting
dark now a month later on Christmas Eve
he took hold of a hunting knife and
headed out to satisfy his bloodlust his
first victim was a woman coming out of a
grocery store
Berkowitz stabbed her several times
before she managed to run away he then
came across a 15 year old by the name of
Michelle Forman she was stabbed six
times but fortifier attacker Ahrens made
it to the safety of a nearby apartment
at the end of January 1976 Berkowitz had
relocated from the Bronx to a rental
house in Yonkers his landlords owned a
German Shepherd Dog which barked
incessantly Berkowitz would later claim
that this dog was possessed by Satan and
its barking was commands for him to kill
women at the time he was working a night
shift job as a security guard he
recalled that the constant barking
almost caused him to take his own life
after three months that noise was too
much for baka when sandy moved to an
apartment at 35 Pine Street at Yonkers
as it turns out he was unable to avoid
the barking of dogs and he took this as
a sign that Satan was driving him to
murder he used a Molotov cocktail to
kill the dog belonging to his neighbor a
man named Sam car when this didn't work
he shot the dog Berkowitz was convinced
that Sam Carr was possessed by the devil
and it was from him that he came up with
the name Son of Sam his two botched
knife attacks convinced Berkowitz that
he needed a more effective means of
killing by June of 1976 he had built up
a formidable arsenal of firearms that
included a 44 caliber revolver a
commando mark 3 rifle a Glenfield rifle
with a telescopic sight Charter Arms AR
7 Explorer shotgun and a 12-gauge Ithaca
deer Slayer shotgun towards the end of
June 1976 Berkovitz quit his job as a
security guard and began driving for the
co-op city taxi company but that job
didn't last long by the end of July he
was working a day job as an installer of
air conditioning ducts Berkowitz's first
kill it came on July the 29th 1976 he
left his apartment via the fire escape
shortly before 1:00 a.m. with his 44
caliber handgun in a paper bag he hops
into his car and began cruising for a
victim he came across
18-year old Donna Lauria in
nineteen-year-old friends Joe diva
Lindsey talking in a car outside Donna's
apartment Berkowitz approached on a side
window squatted down into a firing
position and holding the gun with both
hands empty the chamber Donna was shot
and killed Jodie was wounded and she
reacted by screaming and desperately
honking the car horn Jodie survived with
his gun empty Berkowitz melted into the
night he was filled with the euphoria
that he had never known before and his
addiction to murder was well underway
the next attack came three months later
on October the 23rd Berkowitz was again
cruising for a victim in the dead of the
night he was driving down the street in
Flushing Queens when he spotted two
people in a red Ford Galaxie one of them
had long black hair which he found
attractive
he began following them and when they
came to a stop he parked behind them
Berkowitz had set his sights on 20
year-old Karl De Niro and his 18 year
old date Rose Marie Keenan who happened
to be the daughter of a New York City
police officer following the same
pattern of his first murder Berkowitz
approached the passenger window pulled
out his handgun and fired five times one
of the bullets smashed into Carl's head
but an uninjured rosemarie managed to
escape the car and flee when Berkowitz
left she returned and drove Carl to the
hospital
amazingly he survived with doctors
having to insert a metal plate into his
skull a month later Berkowitz struck
again this time is victims were a couple
of teenage girls jo-ann limine oh and
Donna Demasi they were on their way home
from the movies
Berkowitz walked behind them and as they
stood on the stoop of Joanne's house
talking he opened up with his handgun
then he disappeared bullets tore through
the bodies of both girls but neither was
killed although Joann was paralyzed from
the waist down the attacks they
continued On January the 30th 1977
Berkowitz shot and killed Christine
Franz who had just seen the movie rocky
with her boyfriends as with most of the
previous attacks the couple were sitting
in their car when Berkowitz opened fire
then on March the 8th he killed a
20-year old Bulgarian immigrants by the
name of Virginia Vox Huracan Virginia
was walking home from Columbia
University when she came face to face
with Berkowitz he shot her in the face
at point-blank range and then left her
to die on the sidewalk then on April the
17th the
Valentina suriani and Alexander as so as
they sat in their car at 3 a.m. 'sir
eonni died at the scene while Asura died
hours later police came to the scene and
they found a letter that had been left
by the killer I read in part I'm a
monster
I am the son of Sam I feel like an
outsider I am on a different wavelength
than everybody else
programmed to kill however to stop me
you must kill me I am the monster
Beelzebub the chubby beer mouth I love
to hunt prowling the streets looking for
fair game tasty meat the women of Queens
are prettiest of all
[Music]
by now the entire city of New York was
in an uproar fair over the next attack
by the Son of Sam led to a rush on
handgun sales and a dramatic emptying of
nighttime entertainment venues the
information that the majority of victims
had long dark hair led to an overnight
hairstyle changes women rushed to get
their hair cut and then died the media
was all over the story with coverage
going global but still the attacks
continued with chilling regularity
Berkowitz he next struck on June the
26th 1977 Judy Placido age 17 and Sal
Lupo age 20 were sitting in Lupe's car
around 3:00 a.m. when Berkowitz attacked
in his usual way Placido was shot three
times while Lupo was shot once both
survived a month later he attacked Bobby
Violante and Stacey Moskowitz both aged
20 again Berkowitz fired through the
passenger car window striking both of
his victims in the head the Elan tape
survived though he lost 90% of his
vision but Stacey Moskovitz died two
days later she marked the last victim
of the Son of Sam on March 30th 1977
media hysteria was ratcheted up even
further when New York's most prominent
crime writer New York Times columnist
Jimmy Breslin received a handwritten
letter from a person claiming to be the
Son of Sam it included the following mr.
Breslin sir
don't think that because you haven't
heard from me for a while that I went to
sleep no rather I am still here like a
spirit rimming the night thirsty hungry
seldom stopping to rest anxious to
please Sam I love my work now the void
has been filled perhaps we shall meet
face to face someday or perhaps I will
be blown away by cops with smoking 38
Breslin contacted the police who noted
that the letter contained details of
some of the crimes that had not yet been
released to the public
they allowed The Times to publish part
of the latter as a companion to
breslin's printed response which urged
the killer to turn himself in that
edition of The Times sold more than a
million copies the NYPD formed operation
Omega the most comprehensive
investigation in its history in order to
bring the Son of Sam to justice over 300
detectives worked around the clock at a
daily cost of $90,000 forty five
psychiatrists poured over the taunting
letters that Berkovitz was writing with
the general consensus being that he was
a paranoid
who was unable to form relationships and
with possible connections to devil
worship on the night of the Moskowitz VL
auntie shooting a woman named Cecilia
Davis was walking her dog when she saw a
police officer ticketing a young man in
a car that was parked alongside a fire
hydrant soon thereafter she saw what
appeared to be the same young man walked
past her staring at her menacingly it
was enough to scare her into a speedy
dash home after the murders miss Davis
gave the information to the police as a
result of this every driver who had been
ticketed that night was brought in for
questioning and one of the people on
that list was David Berkowitz a
[Music]
detective tried to get hold of Berkowitz
over the phone but there was no answer
that detective then contacted the
Yonkers Police Station to see if they
could help get him in touch with
Berkowitz the dispatcher he spoke to
just happens to be the daughter of Sam
Carr David's former landlord and the
inspiration for the Son of Sam label
that Berkowitz it anointed himself with
the detective interviewed Sam Carr who
informed him that Berkowitz had shot his
dog and was a pretty troubled individual
the physical and psychological
description that was given seemed to gel
rather well with the profile of the Son
of Sam from this point on evidence
against Berkowitz quickly mounted as
suspected arson was reported close to
his apartment police interviewed David's
former neighbor Charles Glassman who
showed them the nasty letters that
Berkowitz had written to him on August
the 10th 1977 detectives found his Ford
Galaxie parked outside his apartments
although they didn't have a search
warrant they began searching the car on
the back seat was a duffel bag
containing a rifle inside the glove
compartment was a handwritten letter
addressed to the Suffolk County Police
Department that warned of a coming
attack on a disco one of the officers
were sent to get a search warrant well
the officers stayed by the car a member
of the public was told to park his car
so as to box in the Ford making it hard
for Berkowitz to get away if he came out
of his apartment a SWAT team was
deployed around the area
finally at around 10:30 p.m. Berkowitz
came out of his apartment and got into
his car a detective approached and
tapped on his window the son of Sam then
rolled down the window and said well you
got me how come it took you such a long
time
[Music]
the arrest of the Son of Sam caused a
worldwide sensation it turned out that
the monster who had terrorized the
world's most famous city was a rather
pathetic looking loser
Berkowitz admitted to all of the attacks
providing details that only the
perpetrator would know on August the
11th he was charged with second degree
murder for the killing of Stacey
Moskowitz the judge ordered a
psychological evaluation to determine if
he was fit to stand trial meanwhile the
media was in a frenzy to cover every
angle of the Son of Sam story this
resulted in the state of New York
enacting what became known as the Son of
Sam laws permitting the state to
confiscate the proceeds from any
earnings made as proceeds of a crime for
a period of five years after the act was
committed this money would then go to
the victims of the crime as it turned
out though that was to be no trial
Berkowitz pled guilty to six counts of
murder and refused the urging of his
attorney to claim a defense of insanity
he later status I just wanted to end it
I was so distraught I just confessed and
bed guilty and got it over with and just
wanted to get out of that environment
during a sentencing the mother of Stacey
Moskowitz stood up and said I could kill
him with my bare hands and I'm not a
violent person I could probably kill him
and go for dinner and go to sleep that
night
cruelly peacefully during mrs. Moskowitz
a statement Berkowitz repeated over and
over that Stacey is a whore then he
burst from his seat and made for the
courtroom window
he was eventually restrained but not
before knocking down several officers
sentencing was delayed until June the
12th 1978 on which date he was sentenced
to six consecutive life sentences
Berkowitz proved to be a problem
prisoner he reveled in tormenting other
inmates because of his rage other
inmates referred to him as Berserker
wits on July the 10th 1979 he was
attacked by another inmate with a razor
the resulting neck injuries they
required 57 stitches after 10 years of
confinement Berkowitz became a
born-again Christian this angry mass
killer was converted into an evangelical
pacifist he absorbed himself in a
letter-writing campaign to spread the
message of the Bible over the years a
following developed around Berkowitz as
the ultimate example of the changed man
the modern-day equivalent of the Apostle
Paul
Berkowitz first became eligible
for parole in 2002 however he sent a
letter to the parole board requesting
that the hearing be cancelled in it he
stated in all honesty I believe that I
deserve to be in prison for the rest of
my life I have we've gots help long ago
come to terms with my situation and I
have accepted my punishment he has been
up for parole every two years since 2002
but he has consistently refused the
opportunity to seek his freedom as a
result he remains in prison to this very
day where he is considered to be a model
prisoner so I hope you found the video
interesting if he did do give us a
thumbs up below let us know what you
think if you got a suggestion for us as
well leave that below and if you see
when you like give it that thumbs up and
it'll rise for the top and then we're
more likely to see it and make it so do
that if you fancied like I say subscribe
like all that good stuff
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]